[Music]
shannon is with us in lexington kentucky
hi Shannon how are you hi Dave I'm doing
great thanks for taking my call
sure Jude did you survive Derby week I
did you just have to play out a little I
understand I've heard the rumor I love
it oh so how can I help today I just I
can't decide I'm the free spirit in this
relationship and and I come to all of
the meetings that we have every week and
I don't get it but he helps me I just
feel like I'm not I'm we're not
attacking it as much as we should and I
thought maybe you would be able to
either tell me honest I'm a gazelle or
maybe yeah I'm a sloth okay what is it
that you don't get you said I don't get
it well I don't I don't get I don't get
numbers numbers is not my thing and and
the debt snowball will fill on the debt
snowball we have some debts and I feel
like we could be attacking the debt
harder and not and not sending our
envelopes as much as we are mm-hmm okay
so you feel like you're spending too
much but you know we we have six kids
and so Foods expensive and school
clothes are expensive and so we plan for
those things and birthdays and Christmas
and so everything we planned all of
those things out but I feel like we
could be living you know tightening the
belt a little bit more not not living
like we have money because we do have
that okay well the first thing you need
to do is stop lying because you do get
numbers as soon as you said I don't get
numbers you just proceeded to tell me
for the next three minutes all about
your numbers you completely get numbers
you understand what's going on you need
to give yourself credit you need to have
a little more confidence on that I'm
proud of you you really do know what's
going on and you didn't call me up
clueless you know what
going on you can tell him you've got a
really good handle on this and you think
you're spending too much and you're the
spender
if the spender thinks we're spending too
much that's not a good sign so I think
you might be spending too much I don't
even know what the numbers are yet I'm
going with you but I think that's a
possibility so if you see opportunities
to trim a budget and have some money
left over or not put so much into a
certain category you think you're over
funding a category and you talked to him
about that why have you not backed that
number down an example of an area you
think you're over funding okay probably
what we call maintenance
and that would be car and house like if
how much money is in the maintenance
envelope right now and that's kind of
like a little savings account in case
something breaks at the house or on the
car correct because our son wrecked one
of our cars and we desperately needed a
thousand dollars to put it back together
and okay good so it sounds like you did
need it now here's the thing you don't
just because you don't need something on
a monthly basis doesn't mean you don't
need it and so like you know hopefully
you don't need maintenance items on your
car in your house every single month and
so that account is going to build up and
then it's going to go down and it's
going to build up the tides going to
come in the tides going to go out
there's going to be a little bit of that
but you don't want to look up and have
eight thousand dollars in that envelope
eight hundred dollars doesn't bother me
but if you got a big bunch in there and
you know basically you're saying the
house does and cars don't break as much
as we thought they do so we have too
much money in this envelope but yet a
thousand dollar event a while back and
now you've got ain't no dollars in there
that doesn't sound how to control you
might have another
right we have other kids well and you
have you know you have a furnace and a
water heater and yeah and you know an
air conditioner on the car and brakes on
the cars and other stuff and so that's
not too bad what's your household income
Wow great income okay and how much debt
are your twenty cleaning up and then our
mortgage about one hundred and sixty six
thousand turns everything else
yeah the mortgage will be a different
baby step that's baby step six right now
we're knocking out the student loans you
have any other debt we do have a small
personal loan we were not able to cover
the cost of the assessment tank that was
leaking into our neighbor's front yard
kind of like a home maintenance item huh
yeah there we go
item again sitting there right that's
that's there we go okay so good so I
think you're probably more on track on
that one then you maybe felt like you
were but here's what's happening you
guys have been married for over ten
years right how long 18 years yeah and
so up until about a year and a half or
two years ago or whenever it was that
you started this he handled everything
and you didn't look at the money at all
yeah thing to say that we really started
in 2007 okay have you paid off a bunch
of debt tonight we have paid off quite a
bit of it I couldn't tell you what it is
at the moment but we we did have to stop
twice to say for my salary for when I
left work for the child and having a
child and then less work again for a
surgery okay I think you're doing better
than it feels like you're doing I don't
think you're a sloth is there a
possibility that the two of you working
together on this could really tighten it
up and if you have that feeling you
probably could tighten it up then look
at talk to him about it sit down the
next let's do our Budget Committee I
think we're not intense enough and he's
gonna say okay show me where we can get
more intense and that means what can we
trim down and put that money towards the
debt and if you can see a category where
you can do that then do it
that that's all that that's all gazelle
intensity is gazelle intensity is you
run like you're trying to stay alive
we're gonna run out of debt they'll run
like the cheetah is chasing us and we're
gonna run like crazy and you're not
you're definitely not a sloth could you
do better why I imagine everybody could
but I think you're probably doing better
than it feels like you're doing but you
know the numbers are better than you
think you do - I know that thanks for
calling in